hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play SCP
containment breach welcome back I should
say ok so my last save game was kind of
ruined in a lot of ways there was a
series of corridors and I don't know
what so I'm just starting a new game I
got my key card Omni and gas masks and I
spawned in for me just not to waste any
time other than that hey you douche I'm
not going down baby alright let's go
this way now I wanted to go this way all
along if he like suddenly spawns in here
I'll be very pissed off son of a [ __ ]
well what's that place anyway
that didn't actually look like the gas
chamber no I must have been no da man
nah man I ain't going that way screw
that screw everything about that it
seemed weird because he was closer to
the camera than he was previously but oh
the water again the water always gets me
don't know why okay anyway so we're
doing pretty good as far as the keycard
goes let me just jot in here get my 4 20
gauge okay you know yeah yeah make
myself a little happier okay got the
radio here but no batteries forgot
myself forgot to get those for myself
Ludo who do okay anyway so enough
Cillian around we saw the reason we
couldn't continue because we were
infected with the zombie virus and I had
saved my game back there and oh my god
it's a series of tubes again it's a
series of tubes just a constant non-stop
series of tubes is not ideal this is not
ideal either way does this work it came
in and I'm just going in a circle now ha
what would this this is the safe but I
don't need to go in there I could get my
gas mask though I could get my epic gas
mask and pick up no not that and then
pick up a uh hey uh what you Madhu's it
what Gemma calls it what do you calls it
med kit that's right
Kurt chunk grab the med kit just in case
one of the soldier guys shoots me in the
back or in the front or in the dick I
don't know which I don't know what just
works bragging John the dick okay anyway
so I got my gas mask here which means I
can run at SuperSpeed you all know the
deal you all know what it is I'm just
trying to find the last vestments of new
Zeus what is this
oh this is for the two scps okay I need
to pick up the ring I forgot I need to
pick up the ring too which protects me
from mimetic effects like the music
so hey huh wait a minute
oh hello balcony what I've never seen a
four-door corridor before 4-door
corridor before uh-huh I'm a lyrical
genius dammit it's a series of hallways
I did read up that they spawn in more
sectioned areas so the reason I'm
getting a lot of hallways is because I'm
in the hallway area and there's like an
office area and then there's a
containment area so that things make
sense which um the justification was
damn it was with all these series of
tubes is where I came in isn't it I just
went in a circle
cuz no this is different
dammit it's all leading into one big all
right then I didn't see him in there so
I should be fine
yep just fine ain't gon get me cuz I'm
too pro okay
I'm back here I'm pretty sure I've I'm
just going in circles now but I can't
tell cuz ah here we go
okay so that's the music but I don't
need to go in here like not like really
but I'm going to protect myself with my
super ring I fitted the ring into the
slot or which slot being my finger and
you can't run very fast when you're on
the ring but I do
to stop that oh that's a weird sound
give me high you can't affect me I'm too
proud for okay so anyway that's really
creepy seems to be locked door seems to
be like I don't think there's any other
reason for me to come in here is there
there's nothing like here is there I'm
not sure but anyway I'm not dying from
it so that's a good thing
let's get out of here so we can take the
ring off and move forward I don't think
yeah that seems to be locked okay anyway
I'll figure that out at a later date I'm
still trying to find some new stuff here
if the whole facility would stop messing
with me okay
anyway here we go Green Ernie Barron oh
not another one he's not in there
let's go sweep whoop [ __ ] like throw
like the pro that we are oh not another
one unless it's the same one and I'm
just going backwards I'm going backwards
I'm back at the beginning damn it oh I
did a big-ass circle I am a loser oh
that's so stupid
that's so stupid markiplier what's wrong
with you I don't know what's wrong with
me but a lot of things probably alright
let's try to go a direction that we
haven't gone before and let's speed
through it a bit I mean you guys have
all seen this you seen this so I mean
there's nothing new I think we didn't go
left no we went left so cuz that's where
we got the 420 J and we need to go this
way but it's through another thing Thung
and then I need to get through the
thing--the on you to get to the next
area and then we'll be good so where am
I now where am I now
where am I now it's a series of tubes
and I hear you dick series of tubes I
know you guys can't see anything but I
can barely see anything I'm just trying
to get to a new place Dada
it's a far room
I've been here first earn it
ah I'm better before not new
hahaha I've been here dab at it's wedges
this is Oh goddamn it you guys if you
guys can't see I just went to the room
where I found the 420 J again I'm trying
I'm trying to find my way out of this
crazy place
ah I'm stuck I'm stuck I can't go
anywhere I'm stuck oh you know what
let's just take this calmly going doors
that have not been opened before okay
let me just it's a series of tabs at the
endless endless series of hallways as it
ridiculous can't went that way
apparently cuz that door is open I've
gone through this I I'm not I'm not
doing it again I'm not doing it again
I've gone through that one
that one's the dead end this one oh it's
another one okay maybe I went through
that room but I didn't go through this
one oh no I don't know oh no shut up
don't be such an a-hole you in there no
you're not
so go Dinah fire up hi bye hi hi hi hi
bye oh my god that's what ah ah ah to
music again god dammit I can't escape
from it who took that Saget circle they
were the same one and I went through
this one's a blocked-off gate this is
like totally hopeless I mean this is not
an improvement on your level design if I
get lost
ah all right so that's the SCP I've gone
through here before but let me backtrack
because maybe there was one in the
beginning that I missed I have no idea
wasting time precious resources which is
time time is a precious resource have I
gone through here the answer is yes cuz
all of these doors are open all of them
all of them are open except for this one
why is this one not over oh it's a
containment room Slover Virge Virge
ah-ha ah-ha ah-ha founded me Pro about
time about frickin time
where's this oh it's a zombie virus I
don't need to go in there hello duck
anomalous bastard you are no no go away
ah
hi it's about time I got something at
least a familiar face close up you
douche let's go let's go let's go let's
go
don't have no time to waste don't have
no time to waste not to move forward
okay now we're in a different section of
the area took me forever but I finally
found it so good for me man I can't
believe it
alright so anyway we need to find us
shoulder
actually yeah yeah yeah I don't know why
that startled me so much I mean I've
heard that before and that's like what
what what Wow ha ha ha why what did I do
raghu Larry come on stop being such a
joker wait a minute this is just back in
the circle no I need to go that way
radical Larry so uh bring it on [ __ ]
where are you where are you where are
you where are you hi see ya okay going
around you screw you and everything you
stand for let this way right here ah
gotta open the door open the door before
you get through it
gotta open the doors okay oh damn it
it's the elevator I know you guys can't
see much but I need to be able to run
stupid son of a gun I swear you can go
either to Denon I can't say anything I'm
running blind running blind run in blood
I got to get off I can't see anything
where am I
I'm running into a door why am i running
into a door why am i running into a
where am I going
whoa it is still dark the gas mask is
what up
I'm just running into a dead end wall
where am I wait a minute what duct where
am I what's that door why are there
doors here shouldn't be doors here there
button no where did I run to Oh No
there's another door with no button
what's going on here oh not you not you
hi hi
there why shouldn't test hello
I don't see him I don't think he's here
look maybe he is here and he's just
waiting okay whatever let's go see
ah let's not see Barry whatever oh oh
god damn it
Oh huh oh man wake up drums oh oh man
that was not cool where did he come from
those not cool we're all we came from
that door huh look oh man I'm not going
in there
screw that oh man alright so anyway
there's a series of doors down here that
lead to nothing I'm just I'm guessing
they're just zombie doors and they they
open up into zombie nasai guess seems to
be locked up it'll open up in a second
save go man go amen so nice oh alright
okay through here huh alright let's not
mess around with the [ __ ] this I
heard that well Bobby right there hi hah
yeah did I blink I blink I wasn't
watching my blanket bar
I like these [ __ ] these damn dirty
[ __ ] and my frame rate is dropping
which probably means my game is gonna
crash oh you're not there anymore
well there you are hey let's go
backwards backwards backwards backwards
backwards to the door get through door
close the door close the door
take off the guns mask we're good oh
[ __ ] ah
no no no no no no no no no no this isn't
fair now
oh I'm stuck
that was not a good situation to be in
that was like the worst of the worst
like conglomerating into a a hellhole
for markiplier specifically a memory
access violation fantastic for some
reason that scp-096 makes my memory go
wonky so I don't know why but I I know
there's still a lot of bugs to work out
don't know why but I'm all out of time
anyway so I'm happy to be out of that
stupid facility I hate that facilities
oh not the game the facility so anyway
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
Oh
Wow